creeps are making weird AI porn of her
I'm not going to show the pictures I
haven't seen the pictures I've seen like
tiny little Corners blurred out of the
pictures and I'm not even going to show
those very very creepy and reportedly
some of the pictures involve uh Taylor
Swift in degrading sexual acts at
football games because she's dating that
football player and all sorts of other
things but really really vile degrading
stuff and Taylor is threatening legal
action here and I hope taking legal
action this is a form of sexual violence
I'm going to I know I'm going to sound
like a huge feminist and a Swifty I
guess but it's a deeply conservative
perspective that this is not just some
funny thing this is not just harmless
this is not just oh well some pranksters
on the internet this is a form of sexual
violence and the reason it's a form of
sexual violence is because sex is about
more than the body